schon eigenen kindern das darunter nicht
nur die model figur leidet sofern man
denn je eine halbe packung natürlich
keiner
kreisklasse 6 laut um eine ganz
grundsätzliche desorientiertheit darüber
was wirklich wichtig ist im leben ganz
besonders hart trifft es gerade jungen
coolen menschen in europas metropolen
die buchstaben oder neudeutsch genannt
wenn die kinder kriegen dann fahren die
emotionen achterbahnen
wir reichen die marie kreutzer hat einen
bittersüßen film darüber gedreht unter
dem titel was hat uns los so ruiniert
jetzt bei uns ab nächster woche im kino
drei paare wetteifern um das perfekte
leben sind jung kreativ erfolg und nun
auch noch schwanger
[Musik]
der film war nicht meine idee also ich
war zwar damals als ich begonnen habe zu
schreiben irgendwie haltung mit einem
halbjährigen klingt immer am spielplatz
aber wie kann man sich vor allem von
produzenten
er hatte mir für treibt von der sonne
turbo eltern komödie und ich blicke sie
voller ich muss nur aufschreiben kant
und drehbuchautor inzwischen für den
marie kreutzer hörte genau hin
sie kennt die hohen erwartungen junger
eltern und trifft ihn tun
nach der horror kanzler unterschätzen
wenn du sie noch nie volle breitseite
du weißt einfach dass wir wirklich alles
so viel besser und so ganz anders machen
wird also alle die vor dir da war dass
du die welt in staunen versetzen mit
einer grünen und einer liebe und der
makellosigkeit des bindegewebes und dort
gehört
das ist kein zurück mehr gibt keine
ahnung ich würde sagen was nicht dann
lässt sich für interessierte panik über
dieser trank für optimierung zur
selbstoptimierung für die optimierung
der gegenstände da der wohnumgebung des
freundeskreises und daneben auch die
kinder diese optimierung waren diese
sucht nach perfektion verkompliziert vor
allem einiges zum beispiel den menüplan
der photokina mit dem weiß nicht recht
natürlich kein eis mehr
selbstständigkeit und wenn wir die halle
einer impfung geraten in eine veraltete
vorstellung von gesund oder also das ist
eigentlich ein film über lockruf
probleme und ich finde da ist er aber
auf seine art für mich nicht
vordergründig aber dann doch politisch
weil es eigentlich um eine generation
von menschen die man in einer in einem
teil der welt in dem man tatsächlich
keine ahnung form hat also in welche
kindergruppe geht ins kino gibt's
rosinen oder nicht auch ohne probleme
macht sich das gefühl von einsamkeit und
leere breit
und unerträgliche langeweile auf dem
spielplatz
[Musik]
sie zu selten glück aus
im prinzip zu wenige andere probleme
haben uns das hin zu viel damit
beschäftigen können wir alles tun also
in allen fragen geklärt und dann ganz
geforderten sich in der frage der
familie und der kindererziehung kreuzes
milieustudie entlarvt wohlstand als
eigentliche ursache der unzufriedenheit
viel sicher trifft die regisseurin ein
weit verbreitetes lebensgefühl das
ständig hin und her pendelt zwischen der
sehnsucht nach jerewan unter lust auf
latte macchiato dabei stellt sie ihre
figuren aber die blues macht sich nicht
über sie lustig wenn marie kreutzer weiß
im grunde sind wir doch alle ein
bisschen was übrigens mit live passiert
wenn die erste verkauf zeit vorbei ist
darüber philosophiert aller demo zum
kommenden sonntag in der dazu passenden
sternstunde